da gufi la guardo giallo sotto la spugna
mi è mai capitato di sentire
improvvisamente un terribile odore
nell'aria e non riuscire a individuare
la causa di tale fedor e ritrovate
invischiati in una caccia al bosone
stupido cavallo se forse tu oppose
qualcosa da nascondere o cacato e la
ricerca prosegue fino a diventare
un'ossessione nega ai calcato d'un forse
ma dove ti nascondi forma giazza
scatoloni oa scoraggiati nel fallimento
di consolate con il vostro più fedele
amico
lui sì che non vi tradirebbe mai poi
l'improvviso presentimento non può
essere il mondo mi crollerebbe addosso
cavolo finalmente ti ho scalato e così
culto il brutto puzzone sei tu chi
l'avrebbe mai detto che questo viso
angelico celasse tanta munnizza
una volta fatta la di rimini è scoperto
iniziato a rivolgerle i migliori esperti
nel settore
se non lo sai fare tu chi dedichi chi lo
sa fare ho capito ma se di una goletta
degli anni
veterinario è pronto proprio la nazione
sono solo ma non mi arrendero b e c
andiamo a fare il bagnetto
i ragazzi oggi fare un bagno nudo
purtroppo non ho i mezzi e gli strumenti
i soldi per poterlo portare a un
professionista perché nessuno di voi
vuole iscriversi se volete le buldo
abbia un futuro migliore
se volete che pur per un futuro migliore
iscrivetevi a questo canale ed rete
anche al bordeaux che privilegia di un
bagno
partiamo presupposto che bull del basso
quindi quando capita di mandarlo a fare
il bagnetto poraccio che gli fa il
bagnetto ogni volta impallidisce
io so quali sono i prodotti che lui usa
mi sono confrontato quindi sappiate che
alcune procedure che utilizzerò su gould
magari non sono delle cose che dovreste
fare per forza anche voi sudiri
funzionano ed è giusto che vengano fatte
su questo tipo di cane e su questo tipo
di numero detto ciò il rischio è che
faccia un macello totale è il mio primo
bagno ragazzi e sono molto contento
perché era il mio sogno da una vita 28
anni il suo primo bagno domestico sei
pronto entrare nella vasca loc
ho portato per farlo stare buono dei
croccantini una cosa che dobbiamo
assolutamente evitare e bagnardi le
orecchie mettere una cuffia mettiamo
lamentiamo la mente acuta no termo per a
bulciago abbiamo la cupezza
tutto è fluido cosa fondamentale la
temperatura dell'acqua deve essere
tiepida sui 35 gradi non troppo fredda
per evitare di raffreddarlo non troppo
caldo perché so questi qui scofano
volevo dire bugie fermo oggi diventa di
700 chiede posso darglielo subito
chiesto cosa è un pezzetto di carne non
mangiare per qualcun altro
quanti paniere della mamma guarda giallo
sotto smat ha detto perche quando taluni
di in primera doccia per avanti di fuori
di spiaggia e mare
così è stato in honduras dammi gianni
peteani g disco pechino sono dolci e
domani proprio a premi ci credo ma è che
garda sympany o dice fatto fregare da un
cappello appoggiato e gamer che canzone
soul i gatti marinaro puri cibo per cani
più tristi e sapone rinfrescante da un
paio di ogni età che poco poco se ne
accorge infatti non so se lei era sto
cercando di far confondere col tocco
delle mani squisito capito come guard
bagno di spugna se si gira porto la
sponda dall'altro lato di sé lotto con
la spugna francia
sulla spugna ea la spugna un regista ha
scoperto di categoria
sai che se no no non grattare hannover
che tenerezza fare con la verde
uccidendo non fa in cui si gonfiano
bravo adesso ho bisogno un po di balsamo
culto tu con questo bellissimo profumi
sul manto è qui magari vostri cani li
infilate dentro una bacinella girata e
stanno da dio è però non è un pochino
diverso quindi ci hanno detto proprio
veterinario compagnia bella di te
sentono più delicati a ben all'ansa
delicatissimo santo cielo mi aspettavo
debolissima vasca finito bravo
bravissimo
bravo spugna e marco due to ok
ammonite ma col phon il punto è che
cacchio con l'aria freschina del forno
andava asciugare vecchio profumi
[Musica]
se no
no no
no no no
[Musica]
non per cercare di combattere
mamma
[Musica]
con l'idea di conoscerlo non mettiamo su
persone per fortuna è una giornata molto
calda e retrò fatto apposta di fare in
giornata calda per ragazzi io so che lui
è il terrore dei mari quando si tratta
di asciugarlo quindi adesso proseguiamo
con delle frizioni e poi lasciamo che il
suo della natura faccia nel resto per
fortuna noi abbiamo mai nelle orecchie
culto e asciutto profumato un santo del
paradiso ovviamente non si fida di mensa
anche tinagli andiamo a togliere lo
schifo dalle pieghe verrà un pochino di
salviettina sulla testa sotto al mento
sulla guancia nella zona dove sei core
lasciando po perché è bello che sei ma
sei bellissimo quanto per la perdi ma se
tipetti ad unirci di amy rimuovi lardo
sarà un piacere questa sera a dormire
insieme abbracciati
ragazzi siamo niente di questo video
posso dirvi una cosa provo piacere
sessuale quasi quando all'interno di un
video riesco anche a portare a termine
una cosa che posticipo dai secoli e il
fatto che punto ogni fase qualcuno
entrava sa se era una roma che mi faceva
soffrire perché sapeva veramente di
morte adesso punto è felice mordicchio
zoe profumato e io metterei like a bordo
una zampa insorti ma lo sai qual è il
suo soprannome quando viene lavato santo
profumino con like per profumino per
vedere quanto sembrava seduto giu il
commissario rex imma la bimba su maria
ci vediamo domenica con un altro video
ciao
[Musica]